[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to the
second part of our exploration of the
most interesting and instructive end
games from the recently concluded
Champions chess tour that was won by
Magnus Carlson in Toronto in part one uh
we looked at five instructive positions
and I was originally planning to do the
same in part two but I changed my plans
when I stumbled on this end game that
occurred in the preliminary stage
between Notre Beck abdusattorov and the
young and talented Bell Russian GM
Dennis lavic the more I analyzed this
endgame the more I realized that it
presents an extraordinarily complex uh
and fascinating position with countless
instructive themes uh and countless
beautiful variations and so I decided
that rather than forcing a couple of
positions we are going to very
thoroughly and very deeply look at this
one endgame and I will try to to uncover
as many of the secrets and explain as
many of the themes as I possibly can in
30 to 45 minutes and our discussion of
this endgame will lead us to other
interesting positions that I will
include in this video now if you're
watching this and you're you're a newer
player your eyes might already kind of
glaze over and you might think to
yourself well it's complex Rook end game
that might not be for me but I challenge
you even if you're a beginner uh and you
like my videos to watch this video in
its entirety I will try to be as
thorough and as clear as possible when I
explain the variations and it is a good
idea to have a chard next to you and to
be prepared to pause the video uh
throughout not just when I tell you to
pause and consider the next move but to
look at it slowly maybe to view the
video twice I promise you that if you
want to improve as a newer player then
one of the things you have to do is
challenge yourself uh to examine uh and
and Plunge in into positions that you
think might be too complicated for you
and uh if you have questions if there's
things that are unclear to you I will
try to be active in the comment section
to this video so please post any
specific questions you have about the
analysis into the comment section and I
will do my best to answer all of them if
there are a lot of questions I actually
might release uh a third video where I
just go over all of the questions that
people have without further Ado let's
Plunge in so the position that is in
front of you uh occurred after 56 moves
at this point this was of course a rapid
tournament Notre had 3 minutes and 19
seconds and Dennis lavic had a minute
and 33 seconds which is not a lot of
time for a complicated Rook end game now
let's get our bearings white is going
forward we are going to be looking at
this end game from Notre Beck's point of
view white is going up and it should be
pretty clear to you within a couple of
seconds that white is playing for a win
essentially this is a battle for two
results and the reason why is not just
because white is up a pawn which he is
white has four Pawns pawns and black has
three but also because white has two
past pawns and the pawn on A5 is the
furthest Advanced of all the past Pawns
in the position it's only three squares
away from promotion and white has
another Pawn the E4 Pawn which can
possibly be used as a decoy Black's King
seems to be overloaded with the task of
stopping both of these pawns and Black's
Rook is very awkwardly placed yes it is
attacking the E4 Pawn but it's very far
away from the a pawn and in order for
Black's Rook to endend up behind the
pawn it has to basically clear its way
through a dense Thicket of White's pawns
which is going to take a lot of time
white is playing for a win and in fact
with best play White is winning and
after only a couple of seconds Notre
backck uncorks one of the winning moves
and there are several he plays the
flashiest and the clearest winning move
E5 check sacrificing one of his past
pawns again this is not the only one but
it definitely is the most
straightforward now first things first
we we have to determine what happens if
black accepts the sacrifice and takes
the pawn there will be many
opportunities for you to practice your
own thinking in Rook end games this
might be the most straightforward
exercise how does white proceed see if
you can generate the entire winning line
and I have two beverages that I'm going
to sip as I as I watch you struggle okay
so the key here is that white advances
the pawn to A7 and Black's King will
have nowhere to hide which is actually
an incredibly important concept that
will lead me onto a tangent where I
explain this concept in Greater detail
white simply pushes A6 and black has two
strategies if black tries to stop the
pawn of the king it's clear that black
is not fast enough The Rook can move
anywhere along the G file literally even
to C8 uh but that's unnecessary Rook G8
and A8 Queen is Unstoppable the second
strategy is more resilient black drives
to stop the pawn from The Rook behind
the pawn Rook takes C4 A7 Rook to A4 and
this this type of position is very
common and very important to understand
the key question is whether Black's Rook
can move away uh with a check if not
then White's Rook is essentially stuck
on the Pawn's promotion square and you
can never move the Rook away because
black will simply capture the pawn also
futile is the attempt to force the Rook
off of the a file black has way too many
Escape squares but in this particular
instance white of course does have a
check on E8 uh and on the next move
white promotes black could of course try
to uh take the newly promoted Queen and
promote his own uh G Pawn but there are
many many winning strategies here one
easy one is to go after the C Pawn with
White's King and when the time is right
to give White's Rook up for the first
pass Pawn when the ensuing Pawn race is
going to be clearly winning for white so
for example you could start with King C3
black pushes G3 now a bad idea would be
to play Rook to G8 because of G5 and
I've talked a lot about the power of dou
DED Pawns in end games and this is a
great example we'll encounter a clearer
illustration of the power of doubled
pawns a little bit later here white has
already squandered the win instead you
can go up King C4 black bushes G2 you
stop the pawn laterally with Rook A1 now
black has to go King F3 King takes E5
King F2 and here after King to D5 black
promotes white trades and actually the
pawn race is close but not that close
white pushes C5 G4 C6 G3 C7 G2 and it
turns out the black's King uh is
actually blocking the pawns promotion
Square we will dedicate a specific video
two queen versus Pawn positions but you
should know that it's a draw if black
has a bishop Pawn or a rook Pawn if
black has a knight Pawn then white is
winning with an elementary zigzag
pattern you keep forcing the black king
underneath the pawn and then inching
your own King closer and closer to the
pawn I won't delve too deeply into this
uh but suffice it to say after Queen E4
you zigzag Queen F4 Queen G3 Queen F3
check black has to stand behind the pawn
and then white brings the king closer
and closer to the pawn and you keep
doing the same thing uh until you
surround the pawn with your king and
your queen okay so back we go to all the
way back all the way back all the way
back of course I was not expecting you
to completely calculate this end game up
until the Queen's promotion but it's a
pretty beautiful line and I just wanted
to hammer home the concept of the
situation in which uh you have a rook
that's in front of the puns promotion
Square what often happens is that the
king the enemy King is hiding behind a
pawn for example if the black king was
on G6 here or if the black king was on
G4 or C4 it would be at least a draw
black actually would be better because
there would be no way for white to force
the king to induce the king to move back
onto a vulnerable square but there exist
a lot of situations where you can kind
of use your pawns or use some sacrifices
in order to force the king back onto a
checkable square and there's a very
instructive example of this that uh I
wanted to briefly look at which I
encountered in I think mastering uh
chess end games by by Johan Helston
which is an excellent book highly
recommended for advanced players uh this
occurred in a game between two GMS two
Russian GMS Alexander ranv and uh Simone
Deus so it's white to play and the goal
of course is to win the game pause the
video and while you might not be able to
calculate the entire line see if you can
generate the winning plan the kind of
stepbystep strategy that you're going to
use in order to win the game efficiently
okay so the first step is indeed to push
A7 which creates a fascinating situation
this should be familiar to you now
White's goal is very clear Black's King
is hiding behind the F Pawn so we need
to force the king somehow onto either
the E file or the G file and you might
say oh but black is in Zug vong black
has to move the king no black can chill
with the Rook black plays Rook to A1 and
so the winning plan here here involves
using your pawns and ultimately pushing
the E Pawn and forcing black to get rid
of the F Pawn you do that by first of
all playing the move F3 which black
cannot stop uh because Black's Rook
cannot stay on the second rank Rook A1
white plays F3 black has no choice but
to trade if black allows F takes E4 then
that merely accelerates Black's defeat
takes takes now the next step uh becomes
very clear if black plays a move like
Rook A2 or even Rook A4 white pushes E4
check and the is accomplished if black
steps onto the G file or the E file
white gives a check if black plays Rook
takes E4 then we move our Rook out of
the way and promote the pawn but Deus
does not go gentle into that good knight
he plays uh the problematic move Rook F1
check which forces the white king away
from F3 and you might say well how does
that help razan drops back and vus goes
back to A1 now it becomes clear what the
idea is if White NOW pushes E4 check
which is kind of the main idea black has
another square with this King that
allows the king to keep hiding behind
the F Pawn and here you might say ah but
I anticipated the situation and I know
that the correct way to deal with it is
to push E5 and this is indeed the
critical idea of this entire position
this is a very instructive concept and
one that occurs very frequently you
berserk the pawn you kamikaz the pawn
and no matter which way black takes it
there will be a check with your Rook if
you have the mission in mind then E5
should be a pretty obvious move if black
pushes F5 then that pawn itself will
become a new Queen black plays F takes
E5 Rook f8 check if black plays King
takes C5 Rook e a check but amazingly
Deus has set a devilish trap and this
position is still drawn see if you can
figure out why so what you always have
to be wary of in Rook end games is the
relative King activity you have to
remember that rook and king can combine
into a Monumental attacking force and
the reason this is drawn involves a
check on
A2 white can run back to G1 but black is
then just going to keep checking if
white tries to zigzag his way toward the
Rook black is not going to keep checking
black is going to inch his King forward
to F3 still there is no check and black
threatens a m on A1 white has to run
toward the center and now walk black
plays King E3 threatening the Checkmate
again and at first it may seem that
white is in fact winning because black
cannot keep pursuing White's King it
will run into a check but suddenly the
black king can see shelter on the E file
black plays F takes E5 the king is once
again safe and you no longer have any
decoy black can just chill with his rook
and pull out the drop if white goes the
other way if white goes King to H3 then
black does something very similar on the
other side of the Rook A3 check and if
King to H4 now a different drawing
strategy black does the same thing with
Rook A1 threatening Ma on H1 white moves
up to H5 black moves up to F5 so far
this line is essentially mirrors what we
saw on the first drank but after King H6
might say well wait a second in the
other line the black king was on E3 and
black can play F takes E5 but in this
case f takes E5 still runs into Rook f8
check and here a knowledge of King and
pawn versus Rook end games will be
really helpful you should realize that
this is in fact still a draw White's
King has moved too far up the board and
even though white succeeds in queening
the pawn this is still a draw because
the E Pawn will force white to give up
The Rook the white king is too far away
for example Rook E8 King F3 King G5 E3
it's pretty easy to see that black is
going to play E2 and King F2 and white
will be forced to uh give up The Rook
for the pawn uh so this is also in fact
a draw back we go to the critical
position after Rook to A1 that was the
devilish trap that D set in order to
disarm the Trap you have to do is first
improve the position of your king and
bring it closer to the center and only
then push E4 E5 and so you see that
there are often two components to good
play particularly in Rook end games the
first is a knowledge of typical Concepts
and pattern positions which in this case
is the situation with the Rook uh on the
Pawn's promotion square and the second
is the technical execution your
execution has to be Flawless and you
have to be wary of traps that are
specific to the arrangement of King
specific to the position at hand and so
first ranv calmly moves his King closer
to the center uh ders plays Rook A4
now again E4 check there is King F4 so
rant inches is King up to F3 now E4
check is a threat dyus pins the pawn and
the King zigzags and Ducks back to E2
now if black continues to check that's
futile the king is just going to zigzag
toward the rook and white is going to
win the game um and of course in a
situation like this um okay E4 check
actually is not well it's probably
winning but I would start by playing
King to
B2 black moves away the rook and now I
would play E4 check and uh E5 oh
actually what's fascinating about this
is the engine reveals a crazy defensive
resource Rook B5 check and Rook to B7
and amazingly this is a draw because
Black's Rook holds both of White's pawns
so I guess here
um probably white should play E4 check
King F4 and E5 now yeah this is winning
so if black plays F takes E5 and tries
to do the same thing as in the line with
the King on H6 here White's King is very
clearly close enough to the pawn I mean
it's not even close the king and the
Rook will stop the pawn but if black
tries this crazy defensive resource with
Rook B1 check you go King C4 Black Goes
Rook B7 and here white actually wins the
game by simply moving up the king king
C5 again black can't take the pawn black
has to play F5 now you go King D6 and
you're just going to push E7 E6 and and
E7 um so pretty amazing how much
defensive resource black has even with
just a single rook and a compromised
King so probably ders should have kept
checking but instead he went Rook A1
which allows white to execute the idea
E4 and E5 now black Tred to check white
zigzags toward the rook and here it's a
very clean win very clean win indeed uh
because after Rook A2 check white just
goes for example actually I would go
King to D3 and then I would zigzag over
to C4 and move up to B5 and the reason I
would do that is because probably black
resigned prematurely black resigned in
this position if you go back to B1 it's
actually a draw this is the crazy part
black goes Rook A5 e takes F6 and black
is able to stop the pawn from the
seventh rank pretty crazy it's still is
not sinking in that this position is
drawn but it is apparently it is and if
white tries to move up to
A6 wow why is this a draw according to
the computer ah because black plays Rook
F7 at the right moment this is really
Advanced and if white goes to the sixth
rank this is called a Ventura position
black takes the pawn with check and
defends laterally absolutely remarkable
this is something to chew on on your own
so the correct strategy here is actually
to go up to B3 and in this position
again to avoid taking on F6 but to go up
to C4 and then to go up to C5 and push
E6 but that's a little bit orthogonal to
the main point I'm trying to make main
point is that often times you have to
use these Pawn breakthroughs and these
sacrifices in order to open up the enemy
King but again you can see what we're
dealing with uh in the realm of Rook end
games one door closes uh many many other
doors open you answer one question a
million other questions appear back we
go to uh the main game abdor of La so of
course white calculated all of this and
played the move E5 check lazic was not
born yesterday he does not take the pawn
we've established that this is losing he
moves up up to C6 uh the idea of course
is to keep the King close to the pawn so
that the the king will be able to stop
the pawn with King B7 and if you thought
the fun had begun No in fact the fun
doesn't begin until now that was the
easy part the hard part starts here so
the next move by abdusattorov is once
again quite obvious quite
straightforward and correct he just
pushes E6 and we already know that if
black tries to stop the pawn with the
king the king is too far away from the a
pawn black loses straightforwardly to A7
but lavic delegates the task he says
okay King you're going to stop the a
pawn Rook you're going to stop the E
Pawn and correctly plays the move rookie
4 which leads us to the first of several
critical positions in this position
Notre Beck plays A Move That should have
allowed black to make a pretty brilliant
draw pause the video and see if you can
figure out the winning approach which I
will say is not particularly beautiful
or tactical in its nature in order to
figure out the way and to understand why
it's winning you need to have a pretty
good grasp on theoretical Rook end games
rook and two pawns versus Rook sometimes
even rook and three pawns versus Rook
with that said pause the video see what
you can come up
with okay so Notre Beck's move was Rook
to A7 going after Black's G pawns the
correct move was not A6 if you play A6
this doesn't work anymore A7 black is
able to stop the pawn with his King and
make an immediate draw if you try to cut
off the king with Rook B8 black stops
the pawn laterally with Rook to E7 the
correct move is Rook C8 check my coach
would often say that surprisingly
paradoxically in Rook end games the
correct move is often just like a check
this is surprisingly consistent across a
lot of Rook end games if you don't know
what to do always consider the check the
point is just to take as many of Black's
pawns as possible if the King goes away
we already know this is winning A6 and
A7 the King has to remain on the queen
side with King B7 and now simp simply
Rook takes C5 black has nothing better
than to play Rook takes C6 white plays
Rook takes G5 and black plays G6 which
leads us to uh the second important
discussion how is this endgame to be
evaluated and you can't just say oh why
is up two pawns it's clearly winning
first of all White's Pawn structure is
pretty abominable and second of all the
more advanced players watching this
should know that in most cases if you
have just an A and C Pawn Rook and kings
that is often a theoretical draw which I
think is one of the most paradoxical
theoretical end games rook and two pawns
versus Rook if the pawns are kind of Gap
toothed is often theoretically drawn and
it's actually not that hard to make the
draw so our second tangent second and
final tangent I promise if in this
position it's like when I used to play
Monopoly with with my brother and I was
little he would offer me you know $500
all you have to do is give me bordwalk
and Parkplace if I offer you a little
trade you get rid of this lame C2 Pawn
which is even a pass pawn and I get rid
of my pride of my position the G Pawn we
trade the C Pawn for the G Pawn the
pawns I colored in green is that a
favorable trade for white well the way
that I'm asking the question you should
probably know even if you're not
familiar with this type of end game that
the answer is no this is actually a draw
whereas adding the pawns to the board is
a win for a white now I won't delve too
deeply into why this position is drawn
we could dedicate an video to it I
probably will in the future uh so if you
want to know more about this type of
endgame you could set it up on chess.com
and dig around yourself in short and I
need to mention this because this will
help you understand why the addition of
a c Pawn is winning for white the basic
drawing technique is the following how
how does white try to win this well
white tries to move the king forward
right King B3 uh King B4 the basic
drawing technique is to keep the Rook on
the first Rank by keeping the Rook on F
one you give yourself the possibility to
deliver either lateral checks or back
checks depending on how white arranges
his pieces so amazingly using a series
of checks white can actually get the
pawn all the way up to A6 and this is a
very important position for you to
understand if white pushes C5 white
exposes his rear and black starts to
check Rook B1 Rook C1 Rook D1 and in
order to evade the checks white has to
go up to C6 now amazingly King takes A6
loses the game to King C7 and and Rook
G3 but Rook to H1 draws this you simply
have to know now you prepare to deliver
lateral checks if the king moves up
black gives lateral checks and white
cannot avoid ducking them without giving
up the a pawn and this position is a
theoretical draw uh again I won't spend
too much time on this we have too much
to discuss but suffice it to say that
this is already pretty easy theoretical
draw so using a series of back checks
and lateral checks black is able to keep
White's King at Bay and already you
should start to develop an inkling of
understanding why the addition of this
lame doubled Pawn on C2 is actually in
White's great favor back we go to the
same position with the addition of these
two pawns and I'm going to have to get
that position again so E5 King C6 E6 E4
Rook C8 check King B7 takes takes takes
G6 basic idea is that you have taken
away Black's ability to successfully
deliver the back checks right the checks
from the rear are no longer going to be
possible because you're going to use uh
your other cwn in order to block the
checks when the time is right so first
step here for white is to optimize the
placement of our King and optimize the
placement of our past C Pawn King A6 we
go King B4 black of course will not give
up the G Pawn that easily and already
you can see if black starts delivering
the side checks white pushes the other
Pawn up to C4 black will probably chill
on the sixth rank now we play the very
accurate move Rook D5 threatening a rook
trade with Rook D6 check black cannot
afford to trade The Rook so black has to
move the Rook away from the sixth rank
Rook E2 is the most reasonable move now
already you can play the move C6 and
this wins the game here you sacrifice
the C2 pawn and you do it in order to
Garner a Tempo without the C Pawn black
would have been able to deliver Rook B2
check here black has to waste a move
grabbing the pawn and white wins the
game by putting the Rook behind the pawn
the trade is obviously losing so black
has to deliver Rook B2 check we go King
C4 we are threatening the move C7 so
black has no choice but to get behind
the pawn black white plays C7 anyway now
we go King D5 and it's very easy to see
that this position is winning we're just
going to go King D7 followed by A6 check
and if black moves The Rook away we can
go Rook B5 check here we can go King D7
and we can actually use Black's G Pawn
as cover right so notice that the
presence of enemy pawns can actually
sometimes help us now Rook B7 check and
a beautiful mating construction if King
A6 then Rook B8 wins King A8 we have
this incredible mating construction
that's actually quite rare uh in in Rook
end games so okay so let's rewind let's
rewind and in this case you can see how
this additional C Pawn helps you uh when
a Tempo now I looked at a couple of
other options I looked at a couple of
other options what else did I look at I
also played around with the move King to
A6 immediately uh which is a more crafty
defensive resource now if you just
blindly take the pawn this is also a
draw now the Double C pawns are not
going to help you again white always
starts by optimizing the placement of
the king now what if black tries to
deliver uh the rear checks with Rook to
E1 again we play King B before and we we
seem to hit a dead end after Rook B1
check because in order to dodge the
checks we're going to have to give up
the A5 Pawn but it turns out that we're
actually winning with the move King to
C5 okay we're actually winning with the
move King to C5 because after black
plays King takes A5 and this is very
Advanced but white has a pretty
incredible tactical resource here white
has a forced win this isn't sort of like
oh you get some position you have to
know that it's winning white wins by
force in this position see if you can
figure out how Okay essentially by fours
the move is Rook to G3 Rook H G7 is
wrong because Black Goes King A6 and
this is again a drop you have to go back
to G3 and the idea is to force the
exchange of Rooks and again amazingly
you can see that what wins you the game
is the presence of the second C pawn and
of course with the conjoined pawns they
do not need the assistance of the king
to stay alive and white is in the Box
white is able to stop the G pawn and win
the game so
that's not going to cut it King A4 is
not going to cut it because we just play
Rook takes G7 and Rook A7 check followed
by Rook B7 is Unstoppable white forces
The Rook trade the only resilient move
here is actually Rook to A1 having
gotten the Rook away from the B file
again we avoid taking on G7 because this
allows the king to move back to A6
instead we cut off the king with Rook to
B3 very Advanced move if black pushes G5
the idea is to play Rook B8 and Rook A8
is Unstoppable so black has to go back
to A6 now an incredible mechanism we go
up to C6 okay black starts to push the G
Pawn now Rog B8 is no longer effective
because the king is too close to the A8
Square we push C5 okay black pushes G4
we push C4 now notice what we're doing
here Black's Rook is tied down to A1
because of the threat of Rook A3
Checkmate Black's King has to remain on
A6 or A7 black plays King A7 we play
King C7 setting up the same mechanism
Rook A4 C6 again black can't take the
pawn because of mate Rook A1 we push C5
these pawns keep snaking forward and
snaking forward until after King C8 and
C7 we are now firmly winning the easiest
way to win is King D7 and King C6 again
notice the role of this umbrella Pawn on
C5 and this is how I will refer to it
the umbrella Pawn because it acts as an
umbrella against the rear checks C8
Queen is Unstoppable so a pretty
incredible winning mechanism here and
again as you're watching this video you
might want to look at some segments more
than once because I know I'm going
relatively fast otherwise we're going to
be talking about this for two hours uh
but you should be able to understand the
logic behind every move now certain
things that I say you're probably not
going to understand exactly why they're
the case like you might have heard me
say that this is a drawing say why is
this a draw can't I go King how what is
the difference between this and the end
game that we were looking at there's
always an answer to the question this is
why I encourage you to ask questions in
the comment section for example in this
situation the reason it's a draw is
because Black's Rook is no longer tied
down to the a file black is able to
deliver a series of lateral checks and
now the Double C pawns are not going to
help you okay uh so this is why you need
to play Rook to B3 you need to tie down
the king but most importantly you need
to tie the Rook down to the a file King
A6 here of course you go King C6 is the
same thing so G5 loses to Rook B8 King
A6 King C6 and as long as you keep the
black Rook tied down to A1 Black's Rook
is unable to deliver these lateral
checks okay so that is the reason why
white is winning as we could see with
both lines of Defense either the move G6
or the move Rook to E1 it's the umbrella
Pawn that is The Game Changer in this
case we use the maneuver Rook D5 Rook D6
to force the Rook off of the sixth Rank
and win the G pawn and and then we use
the umbrella Pawn either as sacrificial
bait to earn a Tempo or in order to hide
the king from rear checks and again I
encourage you uh to play around in this
end game but at this point it should be
pretty clear to you why this trade is
actually like trading boardwalk and
Parkplace for $500 the umbrella Pawn is
white wins white the game and so the
move Rook C8 check would have been
winning instead Notre plays what seems
like a pretty similar move it's the same
type of idea is trying to eliminate both
of Black's pass pawns but you might
notice that it's the same type of pass
pawns as white C pawns and now it's
black umbrella Pawn that's actually
going to save the day if black had in
fact played correctly in this position
black has a drawing mechanism and if
you're not used to thinking uh with the
board flip the wrong way you can set
this up on your own board I'm not going
to keep flipping the board because
that's a little bit disorienting but if
you want to set this up from Black's
perspective and think about it then you
absolutely can and that's a good idea
it's black to play and make an only move
that draws the game a very difficult
move uh I think a pretty beautiful move
and a paradoxical one and a very
instructive one I think if you listen
carefully uh and you understand this
position conceptually you have a chance
to find the drawing move okay I'll step
away for just a second take some time
all right it's hot on the board so I had
to make it colder in my streaming room
okay so the drawing move for black here
is actually Rook takes C4 double exclam
you take what seems to be the weakest
and most irrelevant Pawn right it seems
like you would rather take either of
these three pawns instead of the C pawn
and yet taking the C Pawn is what allows
black to secure a pretty straight
forward draw now before we understand
why I should mention that levik's move
is G6 this should lose the game although
Notre Beck responds with a mistake Rook
takes C6 is the worst move in the
position because this is a trap Rook A6
check forces The Rook trade and white
promotes uh the a pawn uh but if you
thought the move as Rook takes E6 again
don't be embarrassed if you make
mistakes look at the number of mistakes
that the players made yes they were in
time pressure but still and my point is
not to suggest that I would play this
any better in fact I would probably do
whoops I would probably do a worse job
than either of these
players E5 check King C6 E6 Rook to E4
now Rook C8 check is the winning move
Rook to A7 gives up the win and we were
just discussing why Rook takes C6 fails
the move that lazic plays is G6 and the
drawing move is actually Rook takes C4
now why on Earth is Rook takes C4 the
drawing move well first of all why does
our brain not want us to play this move
well it seems like this actually
abandons the E Pawn and it may seem to
lose immediately to the move E7 but it
turns out that black has the time to
devilishly take the pawn and come back
to E4 and black is none the worse for
where if white plays A6 after King B6
this is the critical position White's
Rook cannot keep both pawns protected
either you give away the a pawn or you
give away the e- pawn and in both cases
it's just an immediate draw uh the other
Pawn is safely restrained so that
doesn't really work the only other
feasible attempt for white is to follow
up on White's previous move and play
Rook takes G7 now black returns to E4
and the basic idea is that if white
plays Rook takes G5 black can draw the
game either with Rook takes C6 or even
or even with the move King to B5 both of
White's pawns are safely restrained
white can only defend one of them black
takes the other one and after King B5
King D3 Rook E5 black simply goes around
and picks up uh White's E Pawn and makes
the drop the basic idea is that in all
of these positions if you added a c Pawn
to this position it would be losing and
we're going to get something very very
similar in the game so by eliminating
the C4 Pawn black is opening up access
for The Rook to trampoline to the a file
if necessary and access to the black
king uh to move around uh the last three
ranks so the drawing move here is
actually Rook takes C4 pretty incredible
I should just mention that if white
plays A6 uh it doesn't change anything
black can go Rook E4 uh and you actually
get the same situation uh flipped around
here Black Goes Rook to A4 A7 King T6
and this is essentially exactly the same
situation uh as this position right it
seem very different but it's actually
exactly the same thing and oops sorry
that's the wrong position A6 yeah but
White's Rook is unable to keep both of
these pawns uh protected and at this
point black draws the game uh pretty
easily okay hopefully this explanation
helps the drawing move is the incredibly
paradoxical Rook takes C4 and this is
what's amazing about Rook end games like
they don't seem to be subject to any
kind of logic lazic plays the completely
natural move G6 trying to preserve both
of his g- pawns and now white makes
another mistake and yet again Notre
backck plays by far the most natural
move in the position he plays the move
E7 and again this squanders the win what
on Earth was the winning move and if
you're not too tortured by this position
pause the video once again and see if
you can uncover the only winning move
okay the only winning move has to do
with the fact that the pivotal Pawn here
is not the E Pawn it's not the a pawn
the theme of this entire position is
that White's most important pawns are
actually these doubled and lame pawns on
on the C file which tells us that pawn
structure works very differently in Rook
end games so much so that pawn structure
is not important it's not the structure
of your pawns that you have to pay
attention to it's the role that each
Pawn plays and doubled pawns can be much
much better uh than connected Pawns in
Rook end games the point is you have to
preserve the C Pawn with the move King
to B3 okay by preserving the C Pawn
you're able to set up a winning
construction now first of all Rook E3
check uh is possible but here white can
use the umbrella Pawn with C3 uh to
cover up the check so again the umbrella
Pawn is very important but what happens
if black pushes G4 well here there's
another brilliant move again I should
point out that Rook E6 Rook A6 loses
nothing changes there so black really
has nothing better than to push G4 now
wrong would be to play E7 wrong A6 is
just terrible because of King B6 you
have to figure out the construction that
keeps the black king boxed in while also
allowing the a pawn to move forward and
so the correct move is Rook to E7
putting the rook in front of the E Pawn
the idea is simple you're just going to
close your eyes and push that A- Pawn
forward and it doesn't actually matter
what black does even if black plays King
D6 and this is the critical point you
play A6 King E7 A7 and the C Pawn
prevents black from stopping the pawn
from behind black can give a useless
check and you can drop the king back to
B2 or play C3 and A8 Queen is
Unstoppable incredible now black has an
another defensive idea black can push G3
white pushes A6 G2 A7 and if you looked
at the pawn race video from my Pawn
endgame video section then you will know
that it's not about the side that
promotes first it's about the side that
promotes with check black can make a
queen congratulations but when white
makes a queen it's a check and white
launches a decisive attack against
Black's King it's still not over after
King D6 and there are many ways that you
can win the game the easiest I think is
to play Queen to d8 check King to E5
Queen to D5 check now King F6 gets made
it in one move black has to go forward
white gives this check on F7 and that's
it King E3 black gets checkmated if
black goes the other way the simplest
move is just to take the Rook Ki Queen
B1 check now don't go King A4 and get
yourself mated very often when you're
trying to escape a barrage of checks you
go toward the center because that gives
you the most Escape squares it's easy to
see the black runs out of checks very
very quickly King D2 and white is simply
up a rook and you're promoting your
other Pawn so another incredible line
and this means both defensive options
for black are losing King D6 loses to A6
G3 also loses to A6 the final idea is to
say well I am going to stubborn stop the
pawn from behind and it's the move Rook
to E1 it's the move Rook to E1 if you
play A6 you allow the drawing
construction that should be very
familiar to by now A7 King T6 and The
Rook is overloaded so all hands on deck
right in Rook end games all of the
pieces need to cooperate King goes back
and says no posa Ron no you will not get
your Rook over to A1 Black is not done
black plays Rook E4 and says yes I will
and now white pushes A6 and by
sacrificing the ewn you earn yourself a
Tempo A7 Rook A4 if it was black to move
then King D6 would draw with white to
move you're able to move your Rook away
and now a beautiful winning idea G3 E7
King D7 and there are many ways to win
but by far the most elegant is E8 Queen
and then A8 Queen Rook G8 picking up the
rook and black plays G2 black is so
close Rook A1 and white is able to stop
and win the pawn with Rook G1 try how
about them apples folks let's go through
that line one more time black plays Rook
E1 white drops back to B2 and by the way
if you try to do the same thing here
again black earns a Tempo and actually
here if white goes Rook to A7 G3 E7
black can draw the game with Rook to E1
and Black's Pawn is just far enough
along so here you go King to B2 Rook to
E4 A6 sacking the pawn to earn a tempo
Rook A4 move the Rook away E7 E8 A8 Rook
G8 winning The Rook how about them
apples what a line and so the winning
line is is to go King to B3 and to
preserve both your leading pawn and your
umbrella Pawn okay that is what Notre
Beck missed instead after G6 he plays
the move E7 lavic correctly pushes G4
there isn't much else to do okay now now
Notre Beck reverts back to the correct
plan and he push plays the move King to
B3 okay if instead he had gone Rook A6
check and after King B7 Rook takes G6
Rook takes C7 Rook takes G4 black draws
the game by eliminating the a pawn and
black doesn't even have to give up this
C Pawn this is just an easy dead draw
the extra Pawn is now meaningless so
instead Notre Beck plays King to B3 and
for the final time lavic misses a
brilliant drawing resource after he
makes the next move which once again is
by far the most natural move he loses is
the game and Notre Beck's technique is
Flawless the question that I'll ask you
is which of the G pawns do you push do
you push the umbrella Pawn or do you
push the leading Pawn black to play and
save the game okay the correct answer
and if you've been paying attention to
the theme of this video it's the
importance of the umbrella Pawn the
correct move was G5 resisting the human
temptation to push the pawn that's
closest to promotion with only a couple
of seconds left lazic pushes G3 but the
problem with this move should be pretty
transparent to you the problem is that
black simply loses both of his G pawns
and he's unable to get the a pawn in
return white pushes Rook A6 check and
we'll look at the rest of the game first
and then we'll revert back and see why
G5 was winning King to B7 Rook takes G6
Rook takes C7 Rook takes G3 and this is
a winning position and once again if you
had exchanged the umbrella Pawn for
black C Pawn it would be a theoretical
draw Ultimate Paradox the reason this is
winning and let's look at the rest of
the game is after Rook e won Notre
backck plays King A4 and as you should
already know this umbrella Pawn allows
white to escape the rear checks now
lazic lost without much of a fight he
played Rook A1 check white played King
B5 if white if black Waits with Rook A2
white delivers uh the side check and at
this point white can play King takes C5
if Rook takes A5 check then King B6 with
unstoppable meate and if Rook takes E2
you might say well didn't you just say
that this is a draw well it normally is
a draw but here Black's king is too far
back and white wins in pretty
transparent Fashion King to B5
zigzagging forward to C6 and now you
just push C5 black is too far back and
black can't even take on A5 because of
King B6 so again I won't get to bog down
here other than to say this is a pretty
easy win if black Waits uh you can just
go C5 and then you can go for example
example um probably A6 is wrong um the
computer indicates King to C6 black
continues to wait and now you can play
Let's see ah you can play Rook G8 check
King A7 and you can play King to D6 and
this is quite brilliant black plays King
B7 and now the other Pawn acts as a
decoy forcing the king away you go C6
and you get the Lucina position you get
the Lucina position because you toss the
king over to the a file now you can just
go C7 uh and C8 so you can do a little
bit of investigating yourself but the
fact of the matter is that if black king
is pushed at the back rank this actually
becomes a winning end game now Rook A2
would have been most resilient lazic
panics and he gives up the pawn and of
course now we already know that with the
presence of the umbrella Pawn this is a
winning end game Black's only serious
attempt is King A6 and now the final
finesse Rook G6 check excellent move
King takes A5 and the final winning idea
by white C if you can figure out the
most efficient path to Victory white to
play the final exercise so the correct
move is not Rook G8 because again this
is a familiar situation Black Goes King
A6 and King B7 instead you drop the Rook
back to G3 and it's a brilliant uh
instance yet again the umbrella Pawn
wins you the game we actually I think
had almost this exact position in one of
the variations if black goes back this
is definitely a familiar idea you force
The Rook trade and if Black Goes forward
then so do you Rook G8 and again black
and outo The Rook trade lavic resigned
in this position because after King A3
check check trade the Rooks move over
the king and promote uh the C pawn and
finally if black plays Rook A1 again you
play Rook G8 and again black cannot
avoid losing The Rook so this is
definitely a great idea to remember Rook
G3 uh followed by Rook G8 and Rook A8
check last thing I'll say say is that
how would white win this you might ask
if black just like chills if Black Goes
Rook F1 what is the winning idea there's
many many ways that you can win this
position uh but one is to go King B5
Rook B1 check and to cover Rook B3 and
if black plays Rook C1 you keep the
umbrella Pawn protected and then just
push C5 and C4 very very easy oops sorry
C5 whatever Rook doesn't even matter
Rook to G3 uh you can just push C4 then
you can push A6 check and okay this is
this is really really easy just go C6
and again it's all because of this
umbrella pawn and so that is how Notre
Beck wins the game um now I should also
add that it wouldn't matter if black
tries to keep the C Pawn protected like
if Black Goes Rook E5 and then just
hangs around the fifth rank well that's
not going to cut it either because here
white can push white can probably push
A6 but I wouldn't even Rush with this
move I would just go King to B6 and
eventually black is going to be forced
to give up the C Pawn because well if
you go King C8 then obviously White
Checks and plays plays A6 so you use
your active King to force Black's strook
away from the fifth Rank and it's pretty
easy to win uh to win the C Pawn here
and so we go all the way back to our
final critical position before lazic
played G3 why does the move G5 save the
game well first of all again for the
millionth time A6 King B6 is an
immediate draw White's Rook is paralyzed
on A7 in order to move the Rook away
white has to give up the E7 Pawn but
that's not really a problem per se Notre
Beck did that and won the game white has
to go Rook A6 check and Rook G6 and at
first his blush after Rook E7 Rook G5
it's essentially the same type of
position that they had in the game but
in the game black had the pawn on
G6 right um and we We examined a
situation in which uh black is a Pawn on
G6 and a rook on E6 let me find it sorry
that wasn't the game
continuation um but it was this position
Rook C8 takes takes takes and G6 this
position as we already know is winning
for white okay this is winning for white
but the position with the pawn on G4 is
actually drawn and the reason why is
simpler than it sounds black plays Rook
E4 preserving the G Pawn white has to
play Rook takes C5 and black sets up a
brilliant Fortress first you tie
yourself down to the umbrella Pawn
immobilizing White's King then you tie
the king to the a pawn immobilizing
White's rook and white literally cannot
make progress Rook G4 King A5 is
theoretically drawn you can trust me on
that King to B4 Rook takes C2 also
theoretically drawn as we've already
discussed okay and you might remember
okay here you can play King takes A5 but
you can also draw the game using these
lateral checks if white pushes C3 black
just pushes G3 and there's no way for
white to eliminate G3 without giving up
A5 every time white inches forward you
deliver the lateral check with Rook to
B2 King A4 you can go G2 that's it you
simply have a fortress okay that is why
having the pawn further Advanced allows
black to set up This brilliant
construction King on A6 Rook on E2 and
we chill we just push the G Pawn that
was the drawing move G5 preserving both
of the pawns as long as possible okay
instead lavic played G3 he gave up both
of his pawns and this doesn't allow
black to set up the Fortress King A6
white of course has King to A4 just
enough to keep the a pawn protected and
again if black tries to keep the C Pawn
protected you are going to break down
that construction okay for instance you
can push C3 and already black is in
zugang either you allow Rook G6 and King
B5 or you allow the king to infiltrate
directly and white wins the C Pawn that
ladies and gentlemen is how Notre Becka
dorov won this insane endgame against
Dennis lavic and this in a nutshell is
why Rook end games are so dreaded and
feared by players of all levels across
chess history Rook end games are just
inherently Ultra complicated when you
add past pawns to the mix you get end
games that are literally impossible for
anybody to play well even the strongest
gmss in the world with the exception
perhaps of Magnus Carlson the best
endgame player of all time before we end
the video Let's very quickly summarize
the key themes and key moments of this
end game and if you've made it this far
in the video give yourself a major pat
on the back congratulations I hope this
wasn't too overwhelming it probably was
but I challenge you to think of that in
a good way it's a good thing if you feel
overwhelmed it means you're working
through the concepts it means you're
engaging with the position and this is
how you learn right it not everything
should be immediately clear to you
that's not how chess Improvement
actually works so to start we have this
concept of sacking a pawn in order to
force the king onto a vulnerable spot uh
we looked at the game Deus ransa versus
Deus where you use sacrifices to get the
king into the open board then you move
the Rook away with chck laic of course
plays King C6 Notre Beck pushes now the
first winning idea was to eliminate both
of these pawns and we saw the role that
the umbrella Pawn plays the
indispensable role that it plays uh in a
o you to win that subsequent end game
after Rook C8 check instead Rook to A7
was played lazic reciprocates with G6
here there was the brilliant draw Rook
takes C4 eliminating one of the C pawns
allowing black greater Mobility with his
rook and his King amazingly even the
extra Tempo is not enough for white to
promote one of his pawns instead lavic
tries to preserve his pawns and Notre
responds with E7 here again here again
you need to preserve both of your C
pawns the correct move was King B3 and
this incredible construction Rook E7 and
then you push the a pawn All the Way
Forward
instead instead E7 was played G4 King B3
and now G3 the final mistake of the game
again preserving your umbrella Pawn is
the theme of this end game G5 would have
been a draw instead Notre Beck is able
to eliminate both of black she pawns and
this endgame is winning again because of
the presence of this umbrella Pawn
okay in the game lvic played this is it
it's where Notre backck actually sacks
the a pawn and another very instructive
idea Rook to G3 and black is unable to
stop all of the threats lazic resigned
after Rook to G8 okay on that note folks
we're going to conclude the video this
was definitely longer than I anticipated
55 minutes again if you made it this far
I really appreciate it feel free to
leave your honest feedback in the
comments if you think this was too
complicated if you think I went too fast
or you think I did a bad job of exposing
the ideas please be honest I want my
content to be as good as possible for as
wide a range of players as possible and
I really really appreciate uh people's
wholesome comments and especially the
positive feedback feels good but I want
to know how I can make my content even
better so as I said at the beginning if
you have any specific questions and I'm
not looking for people saying I don't
get it or this is too much if you have a
specific question challenge yourself to
ask what it I not get What specifically
did I not understand leave the questions
in the comments and I will do my best uh
to look over the comments and respond to
them as thoroughly as possible this
concludes our series on the most
instructive end games from the CCT I
will try to continue my regular endgame
series with a video on night end games
in the near future and I will see you
folks in the next video thank you so
much thanks for watching keep winning
those end games
bye